i mean i'm pretty sure that the
ukrainians will
win
slavo grahamia
euro amslava
ukrainians will win because they are
200 percent motivated
[Music]
hello welcome to martial matters with me
winston marshall at the spectator today
i'm joined by russian writer journalist
and musicologist and author artemy
troysky
and
artemy wrote one book
back in the ussr which i cited recently
for an article on barry weiss's common
sense sub stack and uh
he's someone i've been reading for
several years now
and so this is a real um great pleasure
welcome artemi
and glad
to
do an interview with a famous magazine
um
well
in normal circumstances i'd love to
discuss um uh your books and and your
writing i i'm
very interested in russian history and
and particularly your you've documented
uh sort of russian rock music and and
and youth culture uh in in a way i think
no one else has but um of course four
days ago uh war broke out between russia
and ukraine so uh it's sort of feels
like the
the that stuff will have to wait
certainly for now and and um i'm kind of
keen to to ask you for a russian
perspective on
uh what's going on and um i guess your
perspective may be different from a
typical russian perspective um and
perhaps as uh
that difference is something you could
you could explain and but certainly uh
here in britain we're getting a lot of
the uh anti-russian
side of very pro-ukraine as well as
pro-peace
but
perhaps you can inform us
to what it looks like from the other
side or
or what it looks like in your eyes
well i think that all the same people of
the world are on one side
and those who are on the other side of
the
global barricades are
lunatics
and
people who simply
feel no responsibility for for the
future at all
indeed in russia we have plenty of crazy
people who are totally
intoxicated
tainted by
a militaristic
imperialist chauvinistic nationalistic
viruses
and
yes these people
they are blood thirsty and they want
ukraine to be a protectorate of russia
and generally speaking
you know as warren
boris johnson said recently quite
quite justly
they want to restore the russian empire
or the soviet union they want
you know to spread their influence to
all
slavic nations and so on and this indeed
is uh is absolutely is absolutely insane
and uh
i'm i'm just very very sorry that such a
tragedy
has happened in our lifetime in the 21st
century because uh
well i i honestly thought
that
such
things
have remained somewhere in in the
horrible past you know in in the 30s and
40s so for the 20th century and in the
dark ages but unfortunately
unfortunately this is what's happening
right now and and i'm truly ashamed i'm
very ashamed of
all of all these and
well of course
i think that everyone understands that
uh
putin is not russia putin is a
is a crazy
aggressive and uh and ruthless
uh who uh
uh you know who can
i think
who already put russia on the brink of
of confrontation with the
whole rest of the world
and
this is not
this is not the ideology
that all russians share
the sociological uh
polls
they show a rather
rather grim picture i mean just just
before the
russian invasion to the ukraine cnn the
american tv company and they've
conducted a poll
in in russia which showed
the following results
50 percent well half of the russians
they do support
uh
you know putin's attitude towards
ukraine
uh
25
strongly oppose it
and another 25 percent uh kind of don't
care about it
and in indeed this is a very
gloomy picture i mean i i didn't expect
that so many russians
would support this insanity
but
you know the sad fact is that this is
approximately
approximately so i think this number
will decrease
very soon uh i think it's already
decreasing because a it's obvious that
uh there's no blitzkrieg that this is
not a small victorious war that putin
hoped for
and ukrainians they fight
like real heroes
and
you know it does it does send a certain
message to russian population as well
and second i think that after all the
sanctions that's been imposed on russia
in the past uh couple of days i'm pretty
sure that today on monday it will be a
very very grim
totally panicky situation
uh
at the russian financial markets and
ruble will fall
deep
and
people will
uh well actually they already are
queuing uh
to banks skewing to supermarkets
and i think that starting from today it
will be a real panic
uh which indeed will also affect uh
putin's popularity and
will
uh
decrease the support of this
military adventure
in ukraine
so if 50 percent of
of russians now as you cite that cnn
poll uh do support putin's behavior and
actions what what about it is is is it
that they support do they agree
in his speech last week he talks about
his grievances with
nato with the minsk accords
um and
do they agree with with that side of
things and and what what about it is
resonating or is there
why is it so because 50 is a very
popular that would be very popular pro
war for any nation so what what what is
the mindset of those people who support
putin now
well i think i think it's a combination
of various factors both very traditional
[Music]
because a lot of russians they do
believe in the russia
and a lot of russian are hugely
nostalgic for the soviet union and they
want their country
to be and to feel
like a superpower as a superpower that
the the rest of the world
is afraid of
and and i have a kind of slavish respect
for
so this is uh well i think it's
something like a psychic complex or
whatever but a lot of
a lot of people in russia they suffer
from that
it's one thing and another thing indeed
is
the propaganda
which worked for many many years
trying to convince russians that
ukrainians are nazis that ukrainians and
nato and americans and more recently
there was a new label for enemies
anglo-saxons
uh
russian propaganda they tried to kind of
separate europe you know the germans the
french the italians
who are of course you know very weak and
kind of miserable but they are not so
bad but then there are
anglo-saxons
americans and brits who are the real the
hardcore enemies of the russian nation
and this propaganda indeed you know if
you see it on tv screen
every bloody day of your life then then
indeed you know something starts
to happen in your brains even even if
you are not
very stupid so a combination a
combination of old complexes and old
traumas like indeed russia was defeated
in the cold war and this was not such a
long time ago
uh so a combination of all these uh
has
affected the russian psyche
uh and
and uh yeah it's uh it's a very sad
story and i think it will take uh some
time to cure to cure this mental illness
yeah you in one of your uh chapters in
subcultura uh you write about the 2014
uh ukraine war and uh or or um the
conflict in 2014 and you you sort of
write despairingly
that there was no anti-war
um uh movement at that time in russia on
the contrary there was more of a pro-war
and you and you had extremist factions
who wanted to support the conflict uh at
that time so is there i mean there's
some images we're seeing now of uh
protests in uh moscow against the war
they don't look huge
uh but there are also numbers of uh i
think several thousand who have been
arrested in the actual what does what
does it look like to to resist in in
russia today who is are there is there
more resistance
now than there was in 2014
what is it what do people risk by uh
speaking out on this issue and generally
on putin for those who are not supported
okay well uh there are several points
point number one
and it's a very sad story the organized
resistance the organized opposition in
russia has been
almost totally destroyed
by
putin's uh forces
you know that alexey navalny and and
others
are in the jail
those who are not in jail were uh forced
uh
to escape from the country uh
like me well i wouldn't say that i was
forced i
i fled russia in 2014 you know before
you know the real horror
started but
a lot of people
were forced to leave the country
and
this
of course makes
makes the recession
the resistance makes the opposition to
uh to putin's
regime very kind of disorganized
and and chaotic
another thing is that
the
regime is is really
kind of
how do you call it uh
is uh tightening these screws
they are tightening the screws i mean uh
you know i was i was a participant in in
many
anti-establishment
rallies in 2010 in 2011 2012
i was speaking
there at these huge manifestations in
balotney square in soccer avenue
and so on
and then it was uh it was massive then
of course some things have happened in
2014
uh putin has made
some success with his ratings and
his
increased his support with
this
stealing of
crimean peninsula
well i think it it was it was a matter
of of of pure uh un uh unlawful robbery
you know it's just a next uh
a big piece of another country
but uh unfortunately very very many
russians uh they've perceived it as you
know this small victorious war as
russia's triumph as russia is reclaiming
its past glories and and so on so so the
whole the whole uh anti-putin movement
went downhill for some time
then uh then we had more more protests
in 2018 and 2019
and
then the authorities they started
you know really to behave to behave like
like fascists
i think that russia
generally speaking you know uh i think
all people in the uk and elsewhere must
understand that russia right now
is a true
full-time full-scale bonafide
fascist
country it is a fascist country and no
question about it and the russian
version of
the contemporary russian version of
fascism is much harder than the one of
franco or salazar because
you know just like just like hitler and
stalin
putin's fascism is also
very much about
expansion about
uh
aggression outside of the country it's
not it's not just oppressing local
opposition and and and keeping uh
dictatorships safe it's also about
outer
outer
interventions
just like
just like the 30s
hitler and and stalin you know and this
is scary this is really scary and
everyone everyone must must understand
this and indeed in a fascist country now
it is
very dangerous to speak out
to speak out against the regime very
dangerous
to go
out in the streets with anti-government
slogans and
and you know i really think that all
those people in russia and there are
thousands of them uh who protest against
the war with ukraine right now they're
very brave they're very brave it's a
it's uh
it's a great uh adventure uh for for
those uh
you know who uh
who look for freedom and who
[Music]
uh long for uh for
human dignity and uh and political
democracy
i mean testament to your description of
modern day russia being fascist is that
and you describe in in your book back in
the ussr how you yourself were
blacklisted in the soviet union for uh
writing at that time but it wasn't until
putin's era that you felt that you had
to flee your country
um and
that's
pretty
shocking and i know you're very
outspoken on putin and is that something
that you are free to do because you're
not in russia or were you were you
outspoken against him whilst you was
still there what has that has that
changed
okay well uh you know i have a long case
history of point of being opponent to
the existing uh
establishment i mean in the 70s and the
80s in
in the brezhnev's time you know in the
times of uh
the agonizing cold war
i was also blacklisted
i was
a well-known journalist a music
journalist rock journalist
at that time already but i was
blacklisted from everywhere
in russia for maybe two or three years
between 1983 and 1985
but i must say that
comparing to the current putin's regime
the brezhnev steins
vegetarian i mean i was blacklisted so i
uh
but it did mean that uh you know i've
had searches that
at my flat or that i've been detained or
i've been uh
inquired at the kgb and so on i mean you
know they simply
they simply put health on my
professional activities
which of course was not very nice and i
didn't have money at all
uh and survived
mostly thanks to my parents and my
friends
but it wasn't that scary and at the same
time i've been organizing all those
underground concerts and wrote for some
is that magazines and so on so i do
remember these times you know with great
with great affection because it was you
know it was a real underground adventure
uh right now right now the consequences
of
any kind of
non-loyal activity could be
could be much much worse and and and we
see it you know people get uh to jail
people are sent to prison camps people
are
detained for no reason at all and
that's uh uh
that's much
much worse what was that what was the
final straw for you to leave the country
well i can tell you that
the
the main motivation for us for my whole
family to leave the country were my
children
because
in 2014 when uh
uh all those things with the crimean
donbass started to happen
uh
and the
militaristic and chauvinistic and
imperialist propaganda
was everywhere i simply well me and my
wife we both thought that this is not
you know the kind of atmosphere this is
not you know the paradigm
where we would like our children
to live
we don't want them to become
[Music]
putin's young girls or something
we don't want them to be brainwashed at
school and even even
at the kindergarten i mean for me it was
really shocking when
uh lydia our youngest daughter once came
home from kindergarten
and started to tell us something about
ukrainian fascists
who want to invade russia and we asked
her
where
where did you heard this
rubbish and she said well our
our
teacher you know our
uh
you know lady
at the kindergarten she told us so
and i thought that you know this is
definitely not
not the way we wanted
so this was this was the main reason
because
if i was alone i
i could stay in russia and and fight
there
and
well thank god i've been doing this uh
for many many years when in the soviet
union
but
but
feeling uh responsible for
uh for our kids we decided uh we decided
not to take risks and
and let them grow in a
more uh
safe uh free and stable uh
uh
circumstances
well and and it seems to me from from uh
from my following you that you you're
you're mounting a good resistance even
whilst not in the country um but for who
what voices in in the country should we
be listening to now
um are there
uh
leaders you think in the resistance or
whether
culturally speaking or politically that
you that you that gives you any sort of
hope um from within
um
well
there is
one big political
authority uh in russian opposition and
this indeed is alexei nawali
and i fully support him
i think that he really is a very strong
charismatic and good willing guy
no matter how
the propaganda wants
to
blackmouth him
he's a great person and a very strong
and brave one
uh we have several other uh
interesting invisible political figures
in russia like
evgeny roisman in israel
or ilya yashin in moscow
but
there are not very many
a lot of a lot of politicians have uh
well they've been forced to emigrate and
they are now everywhere in bulgaria in
georgia in in
berlin in prague and so on also in the
baltic states like in tallinn in estonia
where we live now
there's
several
several political
refugees as well
so
these are the political voices but you
know the problem with political voices
is that they can't get united into one
choir because you know some are here
some are there and and many are simply
behind bars which makes it very
difficult for them to
act
then there are cultural voices and here
i must say that we have
we have huge advantage over putin's
supporters i mean those who support
putin are either in a very
dark
very dark and
uneducated people
or
there are some
some people including some cultural
figures
who simply have been
bought
they've been corrupted by the regime
they make a lot of money and they have
plenty of privileges they do what they
want so they enjoy enjoy the same the
same kind of posh lifestyle as uh
the so-called russian oligarchs and so
on
uh and you know these these people are
the uh
the propaganda mouthpieces
for putin
and
here i mean
such such
personalities
like
nikita michalkov a well-known film
director
or valerie gergiev
a
classical conductor
and some other people but not not so
many of them luckily
i mean if you look at
russian writers russian composers
russian
theater directors and so on then you see
that yes film directors
then you can easily uh
see that
they are
all opposing
the
the regime and it became absolutely
obvious and very visible right now
when
there are
[Music]
dozens of
letters against
the war
and proclamations against the war signed
by many
cultural authorities scientific
authorities
you know all kinds of
all kinds of
humanitarian
uh big shots of uh
of russia and
this of course is is very impressive and
this is one one of the reasons
for uh
moderate optimism uh when considering
the general situation
and how and uh
what how do you foresee things now uh
going forward what do you have a do you
have a a forecast or a
do you have an idea of how this plays
out over the coming days or or beyond
well you know i really i've already
failed with one
of my forecasts uh
so uh which was
and therefore and therefore i wouldn't
like to exploit my
cassandra complex
uh i
i i didn't believe
that that putin will
invade ukraine because
among other things
putin is a coward
he was always behaving very cowardly he
always
went to fight with those who are much
weaker
than him and who are in a kind of
underprivileged position
uh so this was the story of the russian
opposition this was the story with
invasion of georgia in 2008 this was the
story of crimea which was simply stolen
from uh revolutionary but totally kind
of anarchic ukraine
in 2014
so
i thought i thought that he will
calculate the risks
calculate weight the the pros and
contrast
and decide not to take this step
but he did it and i think it was a
combination
of two factors first is that he really
became quite insane and that's not
surprising
i mean if
a mediocre personality like putin you
know who
who looks like [ __ ] who's not
charismatic who is not
especially smart and so on but he has
unlimited power unlimited money
uh total
unpunishment
uh
and
and
you know
a perspective of ruling a huge country
for another 10 or
12 or
15 years uh
indeed you know this sometimes goes to
your head and you and you can and you
can
mentally mutate a little bit
so this is one thing and i do agree with
all those and there's uh more and more
of such people who think that uh that
putin is meant
mentally unstable he's he's a psychopath
uh this is one reason and another reason
uh
is that
and this i didn't know
this i didn't know but apparently this
is also so that he was totally
misinformed by his uh
assistance by the ministry of defense by
the
fsb you know the secret police and and
the foreign ministry and so on he was he
was totally disinformed about the real
situation in the ukraine he's been told
that
ukrainians
that that
ukrainian people are waiting for the
russian army as liberators and they will
greet them with
flowers and national
pies
that ukrainian army will surrender
immediately because they won't fight for
the
ukrainian government who everyone hates
so
they thought that it would be a very
easy easy thing
uh
swallowing
swallowing
and kneeling ukraine but
obviously every uh the reality was
uh
was far from that
uh but
and and i
i couldn't imagine
that
that russian intelligence will be
so incompetent in uh
considering in judging uh the situation
so uh
so putin has done this and i think that
now
uh the perspectives
for russia are
are
very well on one hand they're very
gloomy on the other hand they are uh
quite bright
i mean uh
i mean i'm pretty sure that uh
ukrainians will
win
slavo crainia girom slaw
uh ukrainians will win because they are
200 percent motivated very motivated
very strong
their
moral
sometimes forget english words
their moral determination is
absolutely
maximal
uh and
this alone makes them
[Music]
winners of this gamble
and
[Music]
what will happen next
is well there are there are two options
option number one is that after
defeating the ukraine a putin will go
back into this russian shell
and
organize complete hell in russia
it will be
it will be a
full
return
revision of stalinism in the 30s
absolute terror
iron curtain and
total
total
darkness
and
nobody knows how long this will last it
all depends on you know too many things
you know this is uh option number one
and the optimistic option is uh
that uh like it has already happened in
in russia
uh
and
more than once
this has happened after
the defeating the crimean war with
britain and other countries in the 19th
century
this also has happened after the defeat
in the
world war one in in
in 1917
that
the military defeat and humiliation of
the country and the nation will lead to
revolution and
complete complete change of
uh of power
in the country this is uh this is also
possible of course
it can happen in in various ways
not necessarily it will be a fully
democratic revolution it
could be something else
but it will definitely mean
end to putin
and finishing putin will be a huge gift
for both russia and
the rest of the world indeed
do you think there's any angle where he
where putin gets uh what he wants on
nato what's he wants on the minx accords
and there's a sort of in-between for the
for the the two uh
propositions you just made is there is
there uh it's sort of uh a negotiation
in the middle at all or or or the kind
of
um compromise at all or or do you do
would you rule that out as a possibility
no well i i think that the only uh
good thing the only useful thing
uh
that uh
the world has learned from
the current crisis from the current
uh
war
is that there
can be come from my philadelphia
putin is absolutely untrustworthy
he lies all the time he
never holds
his words
he is
absolutely unnegotiable
and
i think that this was
this was something that many western
politicians
have had illusions of
especially like the french you know
macron who kept
talking and talking and visiting or the
germans and so on they all hope that you
know they can
speak with putin as as a normal person
now it's absolutely clear that
putin is not a normal person
and
any kinds of talks or
negotiations with him
is is hopeless
it's as
silly as playing cards
with a cheater
um it sort of sounds like uh the the the
this might he sort of
his ego is getting the better of him at
this sort of end of his
uh uh
time and and it's there's a bit of blaze
of glory trying to cut as much as he can
before it before it's over and that sort
of seems to be
some a little bit of what you've
described in his his egomaniac approach
to it all
um uh well thank you artemis so much for
your time and um uh
it's been rather a gloomy conversation
uh understandably because it's such a
horrible time but um uh as i said before
i'm a great admirer of your writing and
uh certainly recommend uh back in the
ussr and sub gultura too um viewers and
listeners but is there anything else we
can look forward to from you uh uh any
any planned writings where can where can
viewers and listeners follow you find
you
uh
well i can tell you that i'm not
planning any serious writing i mean i
became uh
i became a part-time political columnist
and a part-time radio dj
i have a weekly one-hour long
radio show on radio liberty and i still
love modern music and i play a lot of it
including many many new and
very inspiring british bands like i
think i think that the british rock
and generally music scene now is very
lively and interesting i think there's
some kind of renaissance
i like the bands like say
black country new road
or
[Music]
dry cleaning
lots of fantastic new young bands uh in
the uk and elsewhere so i feel very
happy as uh
as a music
observer and
and radio dj
and it's a pity that a very good friend
of mine
john p hasn't
lived up to these times i'm sure that he
also would be
quite excited about the
the current state of the scene
uh so so this is what i do now but
you know
books uh books is big work that requires
lots of
free time and also lots of inspiration
and
right now it's rather other things that
inspire me and
they
lay in
in in the field of uh
of politics mostly yeah
wonderful well artemis roizky thank you
so much for your time and um
i'm sure the listeners will have been
fascinated by that thank you
yes thank you
goodbye all and slavo
to ukraine and
you know this is this is the victory
sign made famous by winston churchill we
will win
[Music]
you